Aquí tengo representados dos triángulos, y tenemos
información sobre cada uno de ellos. Sabemos que
este lado del triángulo izquierdo tiene una
longitud de 8, este lado tiene longitud 7 y
luego este ángulo es de 50°; y en este triángulo
vemos algunas cosas que se ven un poco familiares:
este lado de este triángulo tiene longitud 8, este
lado tiene longitud 7 y este ángulo justo aquí
tiene una medida de 50°. Entonces, mi pregunta
para ti es: sin suponer que estos triángulos
están dibujados a escala, porque en realidad
no lo están, ¿puedes decir definitivamente
que estos triángulos son congruentes, o podrías
decir definitivamente que no son congruentes,
o dirías que no se puede saber porque no
hay suficiente información? Pausa el video
y piensa en eso. De modo que esencialmente
lo que tenemos aquí son un par de lados que
tienen la misma longitud y un ángulo, pero
ese ángulo no está entre esos dos lados;
si el ángulo estuviera aquí y aquí, entonces
podríamos usar lado, ángulo, lado, lado,
ángulo, lado, para deducir que los triángulos son
congruentes. Pero eso no es lo que tenemos aquí,
aquí tenemos lado, lado, ángulo, lado, lado,
ángulo, así que lo que tenemos aquí lado, lado,
ángulo, es en realidad suficiente para demostrar
la congruencia y la razón por la que no lo es es
que en realidad se pueden construir diferentes
triángulos con las mismas restricciones. Por
ejemplo, este triángulo de la derecha podría verse
así, o podría verse así, el lado de longitud 7
podría bajar así e intersecar por aquí. Ahora,
puedes decir que eso no es lo que parece, se ven
muy similares, pero recuerda: no vamos a basarnos
en lo que vemos en los triángulos, tenemos que
revisar la información que nos han proporcionado.
De ese modo, con la misma información y las
restricciones que nos han dado, podríamos tener
un triángulo como este, y así, por el hecho de
que se pueden crear dos triángulos diferentes
que claramente no son congruentes, con base en
exactamente la misma información y las mismas
restricciones, nos dice que esta información
y estas restricciones no son suficientes para
afirmar que estos son triángulos congruentes.